[Music]
hello there
the best things in life are free well
that's what they say anyway
free to play games have become an
integral part of gaming culture
and are growing to the size of many aaa
games thanks to their focus on micro
in this series i outlined the last 10
free games you may have missed
and also bring your attention to older
free-to-play games that have had
an overhaul this is the 10th episode in
this series which started back in 2017
so if you don't see a game worth your
time in this video there's another 90 to
choose from in the playlist
always keep in mind all three games want
your money somehow but only you can
decide if they're worth it
enough jibber jabber let's go
our first game today a game centered
around the world of assassination
hitman 3. if you've ever looked at
hitman and wondered if slow paced
methodical manslaying is your type of
thing
well now you can try before you buy the
free starter pack has rotating content
first the training missions in which 47
aka the bald dude with a barcode
learns the tools of the trade and finds
out firsthand the difference between
going in guns blazing
or waiting for the right time to make
his handiwork look like a mere accident
the best thing about the hitman 3
starter pack is the free content
added monthly sometimes it will be a
full location with multiple targets to
subdue
other times it will be an elusive target
a game mode which only allows
one playthrough to ramp up the tension
of course they want you to buy the full
game
but there's no harm in taking advantage
of the ever-changing free content
and all progress carries over if you do
decide to spend your real-life cash
next we have vigger a totally
free-to-play survival looter shooter
set in norway vigor does some great
things to distance itself from its
rivals
firstly in this post-apocalyptic world
staying alive is vital
players move into an area and scavenge
for everything they can
supplies ammo and ultimately new weapons
then a slow-moving toxic cloud fills the
map and only certain paths
lead to your escape sounds easy right
well if you die
you lose everything that is on your
character
everything even that new shotgun you
just found
survival is key by taking the loot back
home it becomes safe
until you choose to take it back into
the fight other players will be under
the same pressure of risk reward
and should you all stay in game long
enough a monumental supply drop will
land
and all players will be alerted how far
do you push it
to be victorious fyi vigor uses battle
passes cosmetic items and weapon
blueprints
as the main avenue to making money when
was the last time you played chess
now's the time to return this is auto
chess just like the name suggests auto
chess is a strategy game with some
features like chess
but in reality it's closer to a tower
defense game
and a battle royale game we select our
heroes put them on the battlefield and
watch them smash 10 bells out of each
other until one team is victorious
each hero has stats and once on the
board we are helpless
hence why it's called auto chess this is
an automatic battle
characters are decided before the match
in a random fashion
thus making sure nobody has an unfair
advantage
at least at a base level as we all
attempt to collect the 70 heroes
auto chess is available on ps4 and now
has a ps5 version too
the game makes money via in-game
currency called donuts
and of course loot boxes too back in
late 2020
zelda breath of the wild released on
playstation sorry i read that wrong
gunshin impact arrived a totally
free-to-play role-playing game
which takes the backbone of that
nintendo game and monetizes it with
gacha style mechanics
the thing is this is way more than a
simple copy paste
genting impact is a triple a game in
everything but price
we are set free in a fully open world
with enemy tears to grind towards
exploration plays an important part but
it's the combat that really stands out
each character has their own magical
ability like an element
for example fire and ice each element is
strong against another but weak
against others giving it a kind of
rock-paper-scissors style decision
making to be made mid-fight
the fantasy story is surprisingly
compelling and the artwork and
soundtrack is simply mesmerizing
the game takes your cash via a surprise
random loot box mechanic
which can unlock some awe-inspiring
heroes with elemental abilities like no
others
i played for a while and i've got to
admit the gacha thing
is a little too addicting so keep that
in mind if you have that type of
mentality
don't get addicted
[Music]
next the first ever game on the list
which is ps5
only it's a sad day for ps4 this is
enlisted
a world war ii shooter enlisted looks
like the run-of-the-mill military
shoot-a-thon right
well it has a very impressive gimmick
instead of 150 players in a game at once
enlisted drastically brings down that
number and gives each player a platoon
to look after instead
a squad of four players are controlled
by one person
i know it sounds insane give me a sec to
explain we choose one of the squad
and the ai takes over the rest each of
the squad is a different class which we
can switch to on the fly
if one person falls in battle we are
instantly transported to another squad
mate
instead of respawning outside of combat
this makes fights much more personal and
long-winded
and it's a clever premise i recommend
you give it a try at least
enlisted wants your money through
in-game gold purchases
of different squads from history with
different weapon sets
next up we have rogue company i spoke
about this last time we met up and now
it's fully free to play
rogue company is a team shooter a squad
of players group up on a futuristic
chopper then skydive onto the
battlefield
to either frag out or secure points each
round we start back on that helicarrier
again
and use the blood money from the
previous fight to buy new weapons
rinse and repeat the best part are the
characters
each has a set of abilities and weapons
to choose from from a katana throwing
femme fatale
to a thanos snapping lone wolf who can
see enemies through walls for a few
seconds
each season a new character is released
and the makers hope you buy it with
in-game credits
but it's also possible to do this via
grinding daily bounties
the new ps5 version is out now with 120
frames per second and the ps4 version
runs surprisingly well too
i like roko i hope you do too and
because i like roko so much i wanted to
double back
on another free-to-play game from a few
years ago apex legends
i know you've tried it and i know you
either love it or you've left it behind
by now
well with season nine comes a new game
mode you should try
arena it's essentially the same as rogue
company but in first person
and with only three players per side
this game mode is a fantastic way to try
out new weapons outside of battle royale
arena is a permanent mode so grab a few
friends and jump in
it's a great break from battle royale
and on console at least
it's the closest we have to play
valorent for a while yet
[Music]
anyone into mumbai foreign massively
multiplayer online roleplaying games
mmorpgs have you tried bless unleashed
bless takes the usual formula of
journeying across the land facing lethal
monsters and feral beasts
in a tale of betrayal we build a team of
allies and take back
our lands the classes make up the bulk
of the gameplay loop with differing
skills
talents and fighting styles berserkers
are fearless warriors crusaders are a
little more tanky
mages wield magic and rangers like to
keep their distance like a glass cannon
from afar
find your playstyle meet up with some
friends and take on a god or two bless
unleashed uses booster packs and buffs
to take your money from your pocket and
there's some damn good cosmetics too
next we have a final fantasy game it's
called final fantasy crystal chronicles
remastered edition
light a seven word title wow as the name
suggests
this is not a full game but rather a
snippet as a way to entice you into
buying the full game
by the way the full game is actually
pretty cheap crystal chronicles is the
lost sheep in the final fantasy series
which has always
seemed to stand alone an rpg which
focuses on playing alongside your
friends in a squad
just like bless unleashed the core loop
is down to the class you choose
with cross play set up right away to
play alongside those who have the full
game
and those on other platforms too at
present three dungeons are available to
light players but if they have a person
with the full game in their crew
another 10 dungeons are available too
[Music]
okay so we've done nine and i struggled
to pick a number 10. so here's
two games instead battle operation 2
mobile suit gundam
sees you pilot a mech in a team focused
tactical shooter
it's just had a ps5 update and now has
english voiceovers
and crazy fast loading times and finally
love live school idol festival after
school activity way way home meeting
i can't believe that's one title a
rhythm game to rock out to your favorite
japanese tracks
to dancing girls huh you do you i guess
so that's it everyone is anybody
actually still here at the end of this
video
i'm totally on my own right now oh well
that's 10 more games that are free on
ps4 and ps5 ps5
and ps5 right now i'll check back with
you in six months with part 11.
this is a long-running series see ya